hello everyone and welcome
to today's webinar titled evolution of
host specific
virulence in an rna virus of pacific
salmonid fish this webinar is part of
the microbiology of virtual
week virtual event and i'm susie valdez
of lab roots and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind
everyone that this are active and we
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions during
the presentation
to do so simply go to the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
simply click on that ask a box
question excuse me ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right hand corner of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
those credits
i now present today's speaker dr gail
kirath
research biologist fish health center at
usgs
western fisheries research center for
complete biography on
our speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen
dr kira you may now begin your
presentation
welcome
okay can you guys hear me
uh i think i'm on okay so
uh thank you susie and thank you to
labyrinths this is a pretty exciting
opportunity for me because i think we
can reach a lot of people
with a conference like this it's been a
marvelous conference
so what i'm going to talk about today is
a host
and virus interaction that i've been
studying for a little over 20 years now
it's looking at host specificity and
virulence
of a virus in pacific salmonid fish
which means salmon and trout
now for a lot of you that may be an
unusual set of hosts in order to
consider
but for me i live in seattle which is on
the west coast of north america
and up here pacific salmon are extremely
important
they're important for many reasons
they're a big part of the healthy
ecosystem that we have
they're important economically because
we eat them and we rear them in culture
both in hatcheries and in
farms but they're also really important
just culturally as a symbol they're
iconic for our regions so
they have diseases and the virus i study
is the most significant viral disease
in pacific salmon so this project i'm
going to be describing
is we've been doing it for three years
it has many investigators
and many different institutions as you
can see in the bottom of the title slide
here
so i'm presenting a synthesis uh at
three years we still have more to go but
we've learned some really interesting
things about host specificity and
virulence
so uh this is the virus infectious
hematopoietic necrosis virus or ihnv
it's an aquatic rhabdovirus
with a single standard rna genome about
11 000 bases
with six genes as you can see at the
bottom of the slide
it's originally endemic to the north
american west coast
and it has a host specificity for
pacific cell mounted fish
so here's the hosts it's uh in the uh so
ihn infects only fish
in the pacific in the family some monade
uh and there are many different species
here and as you can see
they've evolved um for a long time
about six million years of divergence
between different species within the
pacific salmonids
we do a lot of genetic typing of the
virus field isolates in the
in these hosts and uh we have a database
of over 3000 field isolates and we find
that 94
of them came from one of three hosts so
these are the three dominant hosts that
i'll be talking about
sorry so these are the three uh hosts
that i'll be talking about today
chinook salmon sakai salmon and
steelhead or rainbow trout
i wouldn't make i would note that
steelhead trout and rainbow trout are
the same species
they're both oncorencus micas the
difference is that steelhead trout
migrate to the ocean and get very large
rainbow trout stay in freshwater and
are also the focus of an intense
aquaculture
industry worldwide so although these
different species diverged millions of
years ago if you look at the geographic
ranges
on the west coast of north america they
overlap
so this means that these species create
multi-host ecosystems where
the virus has an opportunity to adapt
either as a specialist
to one host or as a generalist to
multiple hosts
and it turns out that it's done both so
it gives us an
opportunity to understand natural
co-evolution
and evolution of of specialists and
generalists
in a vertebrate host it's also important
that this has an immune system very
similar to
mammals and so we can understand a lot
of things about the virology of
generalists and specialists
in general for my research program we
start with observing things in the field
because my purpose is to understand
virus populations
as they occur in nature so these
populations of salmonellas are reared by
very many fish health agencies tribal
state and federal
and they do surveillance for pathogens
so we have diagnostics and surveillance
since the 1970s we do a lot of molecular
epidemiology and we look at what's
happening in the field
things like viral emergence events we
try to understand what might be causing
them
so we make hypotheses that we then test
in the lab
uh uncontrolled studies we do a lot of
studies in vivo in living fish
and also ex vivo in fish tissues there
are fish cell lines that we use
and we look of course at the molecular
biology and in silico
and we're studying many different
aspects of this interaction between
ihn virus and pacific some on it hosts
including pathogenesis
virulence host specificity and immune
response
gene expression and viral fitness and
evolution
so my talk today this is a brief outline
first i'm going to give you a little
overview of ihn virus
and the disease impacts that it causes
globally
then we'll look at our current
understanding of what we think is the
evolutionary pathways that has
have occurred in ihn to generate
specialist and generalist viruses
once we describe why we believe that
those are occurring out in the field
we look at controlled wet lab studies to
determine what makes a virus a
specialist
and what makes it a generalist hopefully
i'll have time to describe
at the very end just a new project we
have which is evolution of virulence
after a host jump into rainbow trout
before i give some summaries
so first the overview of ihn virus
ihnv occurs globally as one of five
different
geno groups this is a very simplified
tree of the
glycoprotein gene phylogeny made by
rachel breda
and you can see that there are three
different genome groups
u l and m that occur in north america
north america is where the virus was
first detected and we believe that's
where it was originally endemic
the u virus is also in eastern russia
the j geno group is in asia and the e
genome group is found in europe
so the virus is pretty much in the
northern hemisphere and
we understand that it's important as far
as a global pathogen of fish
because of the 2019 aquatic animal
health code
so the oie is the world organization for
animal health
and they define diseases that are
reportable which means if it's detected
in any member country they have to be
notified within 24 hours
in the 2019 animal aquatic animal code
there are a total of 10 globally
reportable fish diseases
eight of those are caused by viruses i
just think that's interesting
and of those eight three of them are
caused by rhabdoviruses so rhabdoviruses
as a viral pathogen are really important
in fish
and one of those is ihn viruses i have
circled here in red
so when ihn infects fish these are
general disease signs
the first thing you isn't typically
noticed is a rapid onset of mortality
this is an acute virus and often in
culture settings what people first see
is uh onset of mortality and then if
they look closely they might see
darkening of the skin as shown in
rainbow trout in the upper
photo also exophthalmia which is a
bulging of the eyes
which is due to fluid imbalance and
several other
signs including hemorrhagin ascites
uh it turns out that you can also see
behavioral changes
which include perhaps lethargy interspe
interspersed with bouts of frenzy
and spiral swimming or flashing as the
disease progresses what it actually
kills the fish histopathology shows
necrosis of the kidney and spleen
as far as transmission the majority of
transmission is horizontal
by waterborne virus that is shed from
infected fish
and then is taken into naive fish either
through the gills or through the skin at
the bases of the fins
it's also possible to get transmission
by egg associated virus as shown on the
right those are beautiful salmon eggs
but egg associated transmission can be
prevented in cultured fish by
disinfecting the edge with a surface
iodophore
so in cultured fish the majority of
transmission is horizontal
in the wild it's both horizontal and
vertical
we're fortunate in that we have good
laboratory models for disease
infection studies of ihn in the wet lab
involve infecting
fish in this case it's a group of 20
juvenile rainbow trout
that were infected probably a week
before this photo was taken
uh you can see that over the over time
you see the darkening of
animals and the exophthalmia and you can
see some mortality
uh with an acute uh with a virulent
strain you see mortality starting at
about day five and then it continues
uh rapidly until about day 15 and you
can get 80 to 90 percent mortality in
duplicate groups
so this allows us to study this process
in the wet lab
but i wanted to explain a little bit
about the disease impact in the field
as far as disease significance epidemics
of ihn are rare in wild fish
they occur but they've only been eight
documented since 1973 and
all were in sakai or kokanee salmon
those are the same
the same fish species ankarink as nurka
and this is one of the reasons that we
think
sockeye was the original ancestral host
for ihn
we also see ihn epidemics in rainbow
trout aquaculture
in the united states about 80 percent of
the rainbow trout are reared in idaho
in a very intensive culture area and the
virus emerged there in the 1970s and
has been endemic and epidemic throughout
that
area since then globally we also see ihn
affecting trout aquaculture in asia and
europe
uh typically epidemics occur in juvenile
fish and the disease
is acute and systemic and causes
significant losses
we also see ihn outbreaks in marine net
pens in british columbia with atlantic
salmon
where they've had epidemics three
epidemics between 1992 and 2012.
this is somewhat interesting because a
dna vaccine is very effective against
this virus and it was licensed in 2005
and within this industry it's an
absolute requirement 100
vaccination before you can put animals
out into net pens and it's a great
example of
really good disease control that has
been very effective
now closest to my heart is pacific
salmon conservation hatcheries
these are hatcheries that rear many
different species of pacific salmon
including the three main hosts of ihn
with the purpose of releasing them into
the wild so that they can supplement
wild populations that have been
losing in in size due to multiple
multitude of
factors which i i don't have time to
discuss but so we rear
these pacific salmon the juveniles and
then release them in these
in these hatcheries and these are
throughout california to alaska
there are literally many hundreds of
hatcheries in the pacific northwest
ihn was first detected in these
hatcheries in the 1950s and it's been
endemic or epidemic in these hatcheries
in some hatcheries since then
this is what happens at a pacific salmon
conservation hatchery when you have an
epidemic just one example of
a 2009 epidemic in steelhead where
over a million fish were lost and that
was 50 of the production for that
hatchery for that year so
this is a major pathogen
so with all these disease impacts i
wanted to give you a
a synthesis of what this starts to tell
us that
starts to so that we can understand the
virus evolution
ihn is basically in the northern
hemisphere and you can see the
distribution of those five geno groups
here with u m and l
in north america on the left e largely
in europe and j
mostly in asia so if we look over time
we see that in north america on the
pacific coast the first
examples of ihn detection were in
chinook and sakai salmon that was before
1950
and those were in hatcheries in hatchery
epidemics
one of the eu viruses from sockeye were
was
moved to japan so sakai transported to
japan in 1991
unfortunately broke with the virus and
it became established
and then it became also a pathogen in a
rainbow trout aquaculture in japan since
the 1970s
this also occurred in north america
where ihn developed in rainbow trout in
the late 70s and that's the m
geno group and after that we started
seeing
much more ihn in rainbow trout in china
in 1985
in europe in 1987
in korea 1991 and in central russia in
2001
so the rainbow trout industry is has a
lot of ihn and other pathogens of course
that they have to deal with
um the then in 2002 we heard reports of
ihn in sakai salmon and eastern russia
and most recently we have an e
geno group virus in iran and i apologize
for the typo that should be 2017
i don't know why it says 1987.
but so this is the disease impacts this
is what we notice
and there's a lot of description of
these and we start to look at these and
it helps us to develop
an understanding of the host specificity
the original viruses were in sockeye and
chinook
but thereafter we had an immense amount
of virus in rainbow trout
this was due to a host jump and then we
also have some virus still
in sockeye so we have different
specificities these viruses are actually
specific for
sockeye chinook or rainbow trout
so if this is our understanding of the
disease impacts globally
we've used this and a number of
molecular epidemiology studies that have
been conducted on all of these
in order to develop our theory of the
evolutionary pathways of ihn
and that has led to both specialist and
generalist viruses
so what i'm going to describe for you
now is our
overarching current theory of the
evolutionary pathways of ihn
and then i'm going to give you a little
bit of the detail to explain to you
why we believe that this is how it's
occurred so what we're trying to
understand is
how did those five different geno groups
be diverged
globally well we think the great mother
ihn in the middle there was a northern
region part of north america and it was
in sakkai and it was uh similar to the u
viruses that we see today
we know l viruses which are common in
chinook are also very old and
even full genome phylogenys cannot
distinguish which is ancestral so this
is probably a very very ancient
divergence of the virus but we do know
that the eu virus
from sockeye was the ancestor that host
jumped into rainbow trout in the 1970s
and after development and establishment
in the rainbow trout industry it
developed into the m
geno group which then adapted to 15
degrees
and it diverged into lots of different
subgroups so the genetic diversity in
rainbow trout farms is
much much greater than it is in sockeye
in
natural populations similarly the
u-virus was transported to japan
in 1971 as i said and that was an
independent host jump into rainbow trout
that led to the jay geno group which is
now seen in
japan korea and china
the m-virus was also transported to
europe and
and evolved independently into the
e-geno group which is
specific to rainbow trout farms in
europe
we also have a a spillback event
where m virus that had evolved in
rainbow trout farms spilled back into
steelhead in the 1990s and these
steelhead are
pacific salman is again that migrate to
sea to the ocean
and they're reared in conservation
hatcheries
so remember that rainbow trout and
steelhead are the same species
so this is not a host jump this is just
a geographic change and a spillback
that got established lastly
and one of the big topics of today is we
have evidence that the eugeno group
also has adapted to chinook and
steelhead
and become a subgroup the uc i'll be
telling you that whole story
but the interesting point here is that
this subgroup is not specific to sakai
as the ancestral is
the uc occurs in chinook and steelhead
and sakai
so this is basically a generalist
subgroup which has become very very
successful
in the columbia river basin so this
evolutionary pattern has lots of
specialization but it also recently has
generalism so since that's going to be a
main topic of the rest of my talk i want
to just
uh divert for a minute and remind us
what that means
the generalist specialist concept is is
foundational in biology
but for viruses when we say a specialist
virus we mean that it's adapted to
continued replication and transmission
in one host type
whereas a generalist virus is adapted to
replication and transmission
in more than one host type there's a lot
of theory developed about specialist and
generalist viruses
and each has an advantage it's basically
a lifestyle choice for the virus
specialist viruses the hypothesized
advantage
is that if you stay in the same host you
can evolve really really high fitness
in that host and that often comes with
increased virulence
however there's a cost in that adapting
really well to one host
usually results in reduced fitness in
other hosts often with reduced virulence
in some environments a generalist virus
has an advantage
in access to multiple hosts so if
there's not enough of one host around
and you need to use more than one
you need to retain the ability to access
multiple hosts
the hypothesized cost here is that when
you maintain the
the fitness in multiple hosts that
constrains the fitness levels you can
develop
and often virulence to lower levels than
can be reached by specializing in a
single host
so there's a lot of theory predictions
here and what we have
is viruses that we think have done these
naturally in the field
so this becomes a system where we can
test the predictions of this theory
so when we're looking at what's
happening in the field we start with our
database and this has over three
thousand field isolates that we did not
go get
those were all provided by natural
resource agencies that do fish health
diagnostics
we genotype them and then we look at
what
uh and and look at what they tell us and
so this basically covers we have a
pretty good picture
of what ihn virus looks like in north
america
and this is what's shown us for north
america the three geno groups
m u and l they clearly fall out very
strongly in every phylogenetic
analysis and phylogeny's in my work is
almost always done by rachel breda who
is our master
phylogenist shown up above
what correlates with these genome groups
very strongly is host
the m is in steelhead and rainbow trout
the u is in sakai and the l is in
chinook
but note that in each case i say mostly
that's because there are exceptions
these viruses are found in all three
hosts but the great majority of them
are in one host if we look at
the spatial footprint here this is the
west coast of north america
the u-virus which is in sakai
is in the northern part of the range
alaska british columbia and through
washington state
the l virus is in the southern part of
the range in
california and the m is in
idaho and it also extends down into an
overlapping area with the u virus that's
in the states of washington and oregon
so this is a lot of what ihn looks like
out there and there are parent
specialists but they're not
absolute as i said they do rarely occur
in other host species
so for many years we thought that ihn
basically evolved towards specialism
except there's one exception and if you
look right in the middle of that diagram
you can see an area where the u
and m ranges overlap that's the columbia
river basin
and there when we look at the viruses
there
we see they're you viruses but they're
not in sockeye they're largely in
chinook and steelhead
and sockeye and our first hint of
generalism was
that there's a different phenotype of
host specificity
just in this watershed now
there's a lot of this virus about 30
percent of the adults are positive
with virus for chinook and steelhead
so these two hosts chinook and steelhead
also occur in the northern part of the
range
where u is only in sockeye and it does
not access the hosts there
it only accesses those hosts in the
field in this one area
so we were very curious about this
generalist phenotype
and i'm going to explain to you why we
think it occurred or how we
uh how we determined that it occurred
so the question is is u-group ihn and
columbia basin a distinct lineage
this was the research study of allison
black she did a master's degree with me
and the diagram
or the map below shows a closer view of
the columbia river basin
this is a very large complex watershed
it's about the size of france
it covers much of the states of
washington oregon and idaho
so we have coastal areas and coastal
watersheds in the upper left and where
we have u-virus
but those u-viruses in the columbia
river basin seem to be different
the question is is a distinct lineage so
allison looked at all the genotyping we
had done which was over 1200 isolates
collected since 1971 she coded them into
virus detection events
to correct for sampling bias and she
found 114 eu genotypes
which were done by genotyping a variable
portion of the glycoprotein gene
a coalescent tree showed that indeed the
viruses in the columbia basin
are shown in orange and those in the
pacific coast in sockeye are shown in
blue
so she found that indeed it does look
like the virus itself has changed
uh we find that the resolution of the
subgroup you see
is monophyletic with posterior support
0.77 and the overall evolutionary rate
is typical for an rna virus
she did look at what was driving the
resolution of these two subgroups and
she found both host and geography
to be significant so at this point we
have two subgroups of the u and we refer
to the one
in pacific coast sam uh salmon in sakai
as you pee
and that in in colombia river basin we
call you c and that's the generalist in
chinook and steelhead she did a very
interesting analysis
of the ancestral state of host by
and so what you see here is the two
portions of that tree the uc above and
the up below
where the branches are coated for what
is the most probable host
sakai is in yellow steelhead is in blue
and chinook is red
now remember saka is what we think is
the ancestral host
in the upper portion of the tree the uc
viruses were in sakkai originally around
the 1970s
but you see a shift in the 1980s to
where most of them
are in blue and red so they're in
they've shifted into steelhead and
chinook
and those two hosts are interspersed
throughout the rest there's no specific
lineage associated with steelhead
but it looks like the virus is
transmitting back and forth between
those hosts
which confirm which suggests the
generalist phenotype
during the same period if we look at the
up viruses in the lower portion
they stay predominantly in sockeye
throughout the whole time
so we do have evolution of a generalist
from a specialist a specialist ancestor
now if we go back and look spatially
here's the columbia basin
and remember it's actually an overlap of
m and u viruses
so on the left you see the m which is
the specialist for rainbow trout and
steelhead
and it's in the u it's in the lower
columbia basin and in the coastal
watersheds
and then on the right you see that the
uc is in lar
it overlaps that same region to a great
extent
so this means out there in nature in the
same location we have
a specialist and generalist lineage of
ihn co-occurring
it also means that in one of the hosts
which is steelhead
in this region that host has both
specialist and generalist viruses
infecting it so this is pretty
interesting ecology
and it led us to a matrix that helped us
to design
studies to to look into it further
this is a matrix based on field
prevalence
down the left you have the four hosts uh
host subgroups
and so if you look at the ups we think
by based on field prevalence that
they're specialists in sockeye
they do occur in steelhead in chidouk
and rare events
so those are non-adapted hosts the md
then
is a specialist in steelhead and the
other two are non-addicted hosts
moving down the l is a specialist in
chinook
and the other two hosts are non-adapted
interactions
so the top three rows are our
specialists one each
in the dominant hosts of ihn and then we
have
the uc geno group which is a generalist
and remember that the u.p is ancestral
to the md
through a host jump in the 70s and the
u.p is also
ancestral to uc through a shift that
happened in the 1980s
and lastly important the uc subgroup
represents natural evolution of a
generalist virus
from a specialist up ancestor
and this then is my last slide on giving
some concepts for what we learned from
the field and that is that
specialists and generalists are not a
binary phenomenon
it's a continuum in general and
basically for ihn with three different
hosts
if an absolute specialist occurred it
would be found
a hundred percent of the time in only
one host that's on the left side of this
continuum
on the right side of the gradient we see
an absolute generalist would be found
equally in all three hosts
if we look at field prevalence we don't
see either of these absolute ends what
we see
is the occurrence of things different
along the range
so just conceptually we're thinking that
the u p m d
and l are shown on the left and the what
i'm showing you is the percent of each
of those that is found in sockeye hosts
versus steelhead versus chinook that's
the three numbers
so up 86 of it is in sockeye but there's
some in the other two
md 86 percent is in steelhead there's
some in the other two
l 84 of it is in chinook and there's
some in steelhead as well
so this is the quality of specialists we
have it's not absolute specialists but
they're pretty close to that end
whereas the uc we see that there's six
percent in sakai
32 in steelhead and 62 in chinook
so much closer to the generalist end but
not
actually on the end but this is field
prevalence
which could be impacted by a lot of
different things including
just general ecology and human
activities that we may not be aware of
as an influence
so what we do now is we bring this into
the wet lab and test it
so we do controlled wet lab studies of
specialists and generalist ihn
we're fortunate to have a very nice
large wet lab where we can look at
large populations of fish small
subgroups replicated or individual fish
in very many different infection
strategies to test various traits
our design of these wet lab studies is
based on that same metric
matrix but now we're hypothesizing what
we expect to see
in terms of virulence and fitness we
expect
u p m d and l to be high fitness and
virulence in each of their specialized
hosts
and lower in the non-adapted hosts by
theory
the uc generalists should be medium in
each of those but that's what we're
testing in order to see if it's truly a
trait
of the virus host interaction rather
than based on other ecological factors
the design of these wet lab experiments
involves testing viruses from all four
subgroups
up uc md and l and for each we selected
three virus strains
so we're testing 12 virus strains total
that way if we find phenotypes we can
see whether or not they're consistent
within
each subgroup and they're tested in each
of the three fish hosts that are
dominant for ihn
so you can see that this creates a large
matrix and we're looking at many
different traits
the phenotypes we tested were selected
in order to cover
all the possible ways that specialists
and different hosts might vary
uh we are looking at different parts of
the acute
virus life cycle so we're looking at
quantifying infectious dose for each
viral strain
in each host also tissue spread and
in early infection we're looking at the
spread through different tissues
and the host innate immune response
using transcriptomics
we're quantifying early in-host viral
replication and innate
immune response during just the first
two weeks is that where they differ
after early infections some fish die and
some survive so we're quantifying
virulence to see how that differs for
these
in controlled conditions we also look
at a viral shedding and transmission so
that we can see whether transmission
fitness is where the differences are
and we're interested in the long-term
persistence in the field
so we look at the ability of these
different viruses to persist out to
eight months
and long-term immunity so this is
basically the structure of the uh grant
that we're just at three years
in and the questions we're asking here
that i'm going to describe today the
data available is for virulence
early in host replication and innate
response and viral persistence so that's
what i'm going to describe
for you our overall questions are where
do the specialist generalists and
non-adapted viruses differ in each host
and where do the up and uc viruses
differ since the up evolved into the
generalist you see
so i'm going to start with viral
virulence to begin with
we look at virulence comparisons by
exposing fish to each of the 12 virus
strains
in each of the hosts uh one host is done
at a time and we expose
triplicate groups of 20 fish to each
virus strain and then we look
at the mortality that occurs over 30 to
60 days
our questions are has the generalist uc
virus lost virulence in sockeye
that would be predicted by specialist
generalist theory and has it gained
virulence in shinokur sakai
so here's what we saw in steelhead i'm
showing you here
all 12 strains with three strains in
each panel
the upper left is the sockeye
specialists and we see that each of them
causes very similar levels between 70
and 80 mortality by 60 days
after exposure on the top right we see
the generalist strains
and here it's interesting because there
were three strains but one
looked basically high virulence and the
other two were significantly lower
this was explained we think by the
isolation years of these
the virus that still has virulence was
isolated in 1975 so it was a very early
uc
and the other two were from 2010 so
that's more current
in order to see if a low virulence was a
standard trait
of current isolates we then looked at
five other uc strains
from more recent years and we found that
they're all lower virulence
so the uc virus over time has lost
virulence in its
in its ancestral host which is predicted
by theory
in the two bottom panels the non-adapted
md and l strains caused
almost no virulence so if we put these
together
here uh the variance phenotypes this is
the cumulative for the entire subgroup
so for sockeye salmon the up
the upper uh curve there represents all
three strains
merged in the u.p and that's the
specialist that causes high virulence
whereas the generalist is much lower
virulence and the non-adapted
are basically very low virulence we did
the same
in chinook salmon and in steelhead and
we saw something similar and some things
different
in chinook the l virus now causes the
most mortality so the specialist
is the highest and the generalist is
lower
one of the non-adapteds is low but the
other one is up at the same level of the
generalist
and that is the ancestral up so both the
up
and you see viruses are intermediate for
chinook
you see a similar pattern in steelhead
where the specialist is very high
causing over 80 percent mortality the
generalist is lower
but the ancestral up is about the same
level as the generalist
and the other non-adapted which is the l
in this case
is low so this is our
summary of what virulence looks like
under controlled conditions
in each case the specialist on scene in
the field has the highest virulence in
each host
so this virus is clearly adapting toward
virulence
generalist has intermediate virulence in
each host
and the non-adapted strains have low
virulence in each host with an
asterisk to say that in it varies in
some cases it's very low and in some
cases it's moderate and similar to the
ancestral so now that we have the
virulence phenotypes
we can compare that with what we see in
the field prevalence
you remember this is our continuum of
specialist on the left
left to generalist on the right and if
we look at what we found in virulence
it's pretty interesting uh what we see
here is the virulence has been
corrected we've assigned 100 percent
virulence to the level of the specialist
in each host
and then just recalculated how the other
genotypes performed relative to
the specialist and you can see that the
md and l
are quite uh quite strong specialists
they're still pretty close to the
left-hand edge of the
gradient the up is a little closer to
the middle than we thought it is
actually does have virulence
in steelhead and chinook that was not
recognized and the uc
on the right now looks very clearly like
a generalist and that it it
has violence in all three hosts
so this is virulence but what underlies
the virulence
uh could it be that it's the ability
differential abilities of the virus to
replicate
so this is early replication and innate
immune response in the first two weeks
the same 12 virus strains and one host
at a time
we expose 40 vir 40 fish to each strain
and then separate them out into
individual beakers in this time so that
they can't cross-infect
so this is 540 fish in individual
beakers and we harvest
five from each virus strain on different
sampling days shown
on the right what i'm going to show you
is the steelhead data
which we've had for the longest although
we also have the data in other
in the other hosts but i don't have time
to show you everything it's interesting
in steelhead
so our questions are do specialist
generalist and non-adapted viruses
differ in the timing or magnitude of
virus replication or mx response
early after infection
this was conducted by doug mckinney and
david pius and it's a mountain of work
so i need to credit them
what i'm showing you here is just the
frequency of infection
in each panel we see over time from day
0 to day 14
and it's the four different subgroups so
in the lower left
direct your attention to the green
panels and that is
the frequency of infection of three
different md strains
in steelhead so remember that's the
specialist for steelhead
and you can see that by day one all fish
are infected and they
all fish remain infected out to day 14.
that's not true with the other subgroups
in the upper right is our generalist
all fish are infected on day one but
thereafter
we see some clearance and we see even
more clearance
in the uh in the non-adapted strange
which is the
um blue and orange patterns quite a bit
more clearance
so they all get in but there's a
difference in how much they're cleared
specialist is not cleared so then for
those viruses
those fish that do have virus what's the
viral load look like it tells us a bit
of a similar story
and that the specialist is uh rises
rapidly
by day three and then it stays constant
whereas
the generalists and one of the
non-adapted has a similar rise
to day three but then it begins to drop
and the
non-adapted l has a disadvantage it
doesn't even
reach the same peak so for early
infection
we see that it's similar uh replication
early on but the specialists are not
cleared
and they have a higher viral load than
the generalists and the non-adaptive
strains
importantly we did not see a big
difference between the up and the uc
here
so then we look at the mx response which
is as an indicator of the innate immune
response to each of the
in each of these fish in steelhead
i know this is very busy so what i'm
going to try to direct you to is first
the left-hand panel which is the
three specialist viruses what we see is
in black
is the viral load and in blue is the
average
mx response so it rises rapidly and then
there's some diversification but in most
of the fish it rises and stays up which
is true also
for the generalist in the second panel
so as
a synthesis the mean mx response is
rapid
and it's pretty similar for the
specialist md and the generalist you see
on the other hand the non-adapteds we do
see a we do see an mx response but it's
slower lower and much more variable if
you look at the
variation among the uh the blue is the
viruses
uh is the mx response in fish that are
positive for virus
and the red is the mx response in the
fish that are negative for virus
but you see that there's a lot more
variation so we do see some differences
uh interesting differences in these in
these early
time points of infection and mx response
and there's one very interesting thing
i'm going to drill down into the hand
panel here
for the specialist you see that that
blue line which is the mean
mx response drops after day seven
but if you look at the individual fish
it's it's quite a dichotomy summer stay
positive and stumps stay low
remember this is the synthesis of three
strains so if we look at those three
strains
here we see that that's because two of
the strains on the left
have an mx response that rises with the
viral load and stays high
but on the right one of the three
strains has a strong mx response
but then although the viral load stays
high the mx response is turned off
by day seven it's being turned off and
day ten and fifteen there's no mx
response
we found this really interesting because
that specific strain is representative
of the most dominant genotype we have
in the columbia basin and this genotype
has displaced the other two
so it could be that the mechanism by
which it displaced is that it developed
the ability to turn off the host innate
immune response
and we are going to be testing that by a
repeat study soon
so we do see some differences early on
in infection
but what about the later time points
we're very interested in long-term
persistence
and these are difficult studies uh done
by maureen purcell and rachel powers
it's a lot of work uh we've looked at
persistence out to eight months so for
each of the hosts
steelhead chinook and sakai groups of
400 to 800 fish
were exposed to the specialist virus a
generalist virus and a non-adaptive
virus
we had to use a lot of fish for the
specialist because we knew that there
would be some mortality
and we needed to be able to characterize
survivors so this is persistence in
survivors
and if you look at the time points of
sampling in the upper right they were
sampled early on
just to tell whether or not the
virus had actually infected all the fish
and then at one month three months and
eight months larger numbers of fish were
sampled in order to see
whether there was differences so the big
question is
is persistence of phenotype does it vary
among the virus strains
this is very rare to look at such a
thing but we thought it might be
important in the field
this is what we saw in steelhead
prevalence of virus
is on the left and viral loads is on the
right
and you can see that by either measure
all three viral strains got in
uh to most fish and uh at the early time
points on the left
and they had about the same amount
however over time and at the later
time points the specialist is the md
shown in red here
the specialist is in more fish at the
later time points and it has a higher
viral load
so we do see and the generalist is uh
less than the specialist and it is not
different than the non-adapted in
steelhead
slightly different story when we look in
chinook here we have a different amount
of infection to begin with
but the but the specialist here is the l
which is the
red and you can see that the specialist
does have an advantage
in both prevalence and viral load out at
those lower time
longer time points the generalist virus
is also less than the specialist
but five prevalence it's higher than the
non-adapted
bit similar in the sockeye here we have
the
specialist is the u.p and by both
prevalence and viral load there's quite
an advantage
in long-term persistence but the
generalist is less than the specialist
but here the generalist is definitely
higher than the
non-adapted so we're seeing these
specialist generalist
interactions out to eight out to long
term
three and eight months so here's my
summary of what we've learned
so far from the three different traits
that i've
i've told you about for virulence
specialists have the highest virulence
in each host generalists are
intermediate
and the non-adaptive are low but the
ancestral non-adapted
is an intermediate level similar to the
generalist so we do have very
uh variation in virulence infection
frequency and early replication are
similar but the non-specialists are
cleared
more than the specialists so it seems to
be clearance is a very important element
also the innate immune the mx response
is similar but it's more uniform for
specialists and generalists
than for non-adaptive viruses i think
that difference in uniformity is really
interesting in the ability of
these hosts to recognize the unadapted
viruses
for persistence the specialist viruses
persisted longer
at higher viral loads than generalists
or non-adapted viruses
so that last quality is really
interesting to us that persistence is a
variable phenotype
which suggests perhaps some of this
biology is driven by recovery trade-offs
rather than transmission trade-offs
early in the uh
early in infection
so that's basically where we are we are
going to be looking at a lot more things
uh over time we've got the infectious
dose data and viral transmission data is
looking very interesting and i hope to
be able to tell you about that later
but overall i think we have a system
which is um
really telling us a lot about host
specificity and how virulence in the
field
is determined by what happens in the
actual infections which are
in controlled and controlled infections
that leaves me just a little time to
tell you about another project which is
just now starting i have only three
slides here
but we have a new project on virulence
evolution after the host jump from u to
m
the principal investigator here is
andrew wargo with an asterisk on the
left he's at the virginia institute of
marine science
and it's a collaboration between
researchers there ourselves
at the uh western fisheries research
center and uh
and pennsylvania state so
this project basically looks if you look
at this is the north american evolution
uh pattern theory it's looking at this
portion
now the project i just detailed to you
uh looked at
outside this yellow box we looked at up
specialists
l uc and md so everything but this box
so the new project is focusing now on
this box
we know that the u.p viruses did a host
jump into rainbow trout
in the 70s so they've had 40 or 50 years
to persist in rainbow trout and they
have diverged dramatically into
subgroups so
the question is what's happened to
virulence evolution during that time
this is similar to what the following
the evolution of virulence in the
in the classic mixoma study in in
australia
we're doing this by selecting a time
series of ihn isolates
both u and m across the time of the host
jump we have a large archive of ihn
isolates and you can see on the left
we've chosen two m's and two uh this is
a time
on a timeline two m's and two years from
the 1970s which is about when it
happened
and then some from the 1990s and some
more recently from
between 2010 and 2017
this is just a start this is our first
challenges and we're testing virulence
and fitness
in both sockeye and rainbow trout to get
a skeleton of what has changed over time
but beyond that then we are going to
expand into looking at a much larger
selection of rainbow trout viruses so
these are virus isolates from the
rainbow trout industry
where three different subgroups are the
dominant mb
mc and md are dominant and they have
persisted for 40 years so
we are going to see what happens in
virulence over time
and hopefully we will learn something uh
to complement what we know about mixoma
virus evolution in rabbits
so summaries then uh
we're very interested in ihn
evolutionary pathways and so this is a
summary of what we learned from the
field
we collect historical records virus
surveillance and genotyping data
violet we do phylogenetic analyses in
molecular epidemiology
and through this we've seen lots of
interesting things happening
with ihn and cell mounted fish the
general rule is specialist viruses
but we've also seen host jumps emergence
events geographic transport
and genotype displacements which i
didn't have time to talk about today but
that's been very interesting
and most recently evolution of a
generalist from a specialist ancestor
in each case then we are looking at
these in controlled wet lab experiments
and this is my summary of what we know
so far
specialist lineages of ihn virus by
several measures
we see higher fitness and virulence in
each host relative to the
non-specialists
so it's not based on a single trait it's
a multi-trait difference
generalist viruses are typically
intermediate by several measures
including virulence
between specialist and non-attracted
strains and we do see multiple traits
differ between the up and uc viruses
so we're still in the process of trying
to determine what we think
actually happened to develop into the
generalist virus but uh
hopefully we'll learn that in the next
year the virulence of the generalist you
see we know it is reduced in the former
sockeye salmon host
but it is not greatly increased in the
new hosts and that is
uh the first is a prediction of
specialist generalist theory
the second i think tells us a little bit
about where it is along that gradient
of specialist to generalist evolution
both
early replication and persistence are
variable phenotypes
so with that then i will say thank you
uh on the left is the project teams many
many wonderful scientists have
contributed to this
our funding from the fish and wildlife
service usda and nsf
and none of this would be possible
without the wonderful collaboration of
fish health management agencies so the
u.s fish and wildlife service
state fish and wildlife agencies in
washington idaho oregon and alaska
and department of fisheries and oceans
in canada and the northwest indian fish
commission which runs tribal fish
hatcheries
in our region all of these people are
out there on the ground and they
provide us with virus isolates and they
also keep us grounded in what is
actually happening out there
and i think that's been really
foundational for us to be able to
explore these fascinating phenotypes
with that i am done and i would love to
hear questions
thank you so much dr curat for the
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you
want to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question
box located on the far left of your
screen
and we already have quite a few
questions that have come in
oh good our first question is
why do you think generalist virus arose
only in the columbia river basin
that's actually one of my favorite
questions uh when we are trying to study
these phenomena
and we're trying to figure out why they
happened one of the main things i'm
interested in
is what are humans doing that might be
causing this because these are heavily
managed systems
not only do we rear the fish in
hatcheries uh or and fish farms but we
have dams
uh we we have pollution we have all
kinds of things that is impacting the
fish
and what i think uh we we know that the
generalist only arose in the columbia
basin which is extremely complex there's
a lot of hatcheries
and if you look at the history it used
to be a sockeye
watershed and then in the 1950s with the
advent of hatcheries
humans are responsible for shifting the
relative abundance of those three hosts
so humans have basically uh
caused more we we're much more chinook
and steelhead now
than sockeye so perhaps the virus which
was originally a sockeye specialist
perceived that there could not could no
longer sustain itself in sakai and it
needed to shift into these other hosts
this is just a theory but i love the
theory uh
and i think it helps us understand what
might be consequences
of changing management practices in the
future so we do link this up quite a bit
to management practices
thank you so much should we be concerned
with
fish consumption that are hosts for the
virus and
what is the virus effect on humans if
transmitted
that's a great question there is no
effect at all
on humans and this is because these are
cold adapted
the virus salmon our cold adapted hosts
fish in general are cold-blooded
so their viruses are adapted to the
temperature of the host
the optimum temperature for this virus
is 15 degrees celsius
and it is it is inactivated at 25
degrees c
so as long as your body temperature is
normal for a mammal at 37
that is basically too large a leap for
the virus to evolve any any ability to
replicate so
there's absolutely no consequence to
human health and with that also
makes it a nice virus to study in the
lab
dr what about can a specialist virus
become a generalist virus at any point
on time and
vice versa and if so why is that
i think we have to keep in mind that
continuum
that whether a virus is a specialist or
a generalist has to do with what is the
most
advantageous for the virus at that time
so if the conditions change if the
selection regime changes
uh at a specialist virus is no longer
advantageous then a generalist can arise
i think that's what happened in the
columbia basin
if you think about rainbow trout farms
there's no reason for that virus to
maintain fitness in any other host
because we basically present it with
naive hosts
of the exact same species on a regular
you know all the time
so i think it's a matter of these are
lifestyle choices of the virus
um and it depends on what's the most
advantageous like any other selected
trait
it's selected by what is the most
advantageous for the virus
thank you so much we have some great
questions coming in from our audience
members continue to give us those
questions
thank you so much for your participation
our next question
what hatchery and farm observations can
they tell us
about the virus transmission and
evolution in wild
salmonid populations
that's another great question there's
definitely
virus in wild fish it originated in wild
fish
uh but of course anytime you culture
fish
i always say it's just like a grade
school uh you put you put
young hosts at a high density you're
gonna get disease transmission
so we study we have much more
surveillance of
farms and hatcheries so that's where we
know a lot but we also try to look
what's in wild fish when we can
and we see the same viruses you have to
remember most of the hatchery
populations
well all of the hatchery problems are
released as juveniles and they
intermingle with the wild fish
plus water aquatic ecosystems are very
interconnected with water flow so
there's really very little distinction
what we see the main difference is that
we see epidemics
in fish farms and hatcheries which we
don't see very much in the wild
and that has to do with density so i
think as uh
responsible managers we have a
responsibility to control those
epidemics and make sure we don't change
the virus pressure on the wild fish but
otherwise there's not much distinction
between what we see in fish
uh that are wild versus cultured did i
answer the question there
i think you did yeah okay um what about
warming
ocean waters how will they impact the
virus transmission
such as hatchery fish that migrate to
the ocean
that's a great question and there's
going to be lots of differences
uh warming oceans is a slow process
and so we do know that the virus could
can develop it can
uh develop tolerance first for higher
for slight changes in temperature so it
will adapt
uh what we know right now is that for
instance the
l is in the southern portion of the
range in chinook
and right now though chinook do not
migrate farther north than the
northern border of california but as the
but as the oceans warm
we're going to see changing migration
patterns in the ocean when that happens
el virus might be brought up to the
columbia basin it's never been there
before
so we are going to see potential for
invasion
beca based on changing migration
patterns of the adults
so i do think ocean warming uh
it also um causes health impacts on the
fish it's
it's salmonids do not like warm water so
it has
general health impacts uh that are
negative
and we had some very very warm water uh
water years in the columbia basin a
couple years ago and a lot of the
sockeye died
on migration so they were not able to
spawn so
it's going to impact the fish for sure
and the viruses will go along with it
oh thank you so much we have time for a
couple more questions
can you clarify is the specialist
generalists
non-adaptive technically different
viruses
in some sense or are they all the same
just with different
actions to them that is a really good
question i
i am i'm glad that was asked because
it's not the virus
that is a specialist generalist or
non-adapted
it's and it's not the host it's the
interaction
it's got to be this virus in this host
is that a specialist interaction
or is it a generalist interaction so
those terms
apply to the virus and the host in one
host
a certain virus will be a specialist but
another host it'll be a different
specialist so
you really have to keep track of the
fact that those terms refer to the
interaction
which pair do you have which virus and
which which host
in some cases it's a specialized
interaction some cases it's a
generalized interaction in some cases
it's not adapted
good question thank you our last
question that we have time for today and
this is such a great conversation
are you hopeful for a vaccine what do
you see is the solution
to the virus being in the timeline for
it
what do you think another great question
uh an interesting i worked for many
years on dna vaccines
of vaccines i think are a really
important tool
but we have to be careful i have had
people ask me how you're going to
vaccinate wild fish
i'm not going to vaccinate wild fish i
would never choose to vaccinate wild
fish
it's a useful tool in culture situations
in order to control
epidemics so we have a responsibility to
control those epidemics but we also have
to realize that there's theory
suggesting that
if you vaccinate hatchery populations
you may be
actually selecting for increased
virulence in the pathogen
in order to break through that vaccine
and since the wild fish won't be
vaccinated
you could be causing a negative impact
by creating viruses that are even more
virulent
that'll have terrible effects on the
wild fish so while
we do have an effective vaccine it's a
dna vaccine
it is not easy to deliver to the
thousands
or millions of juvenile fish that's why
it's not widely used
but it is used in some cases like i said
atlantic salmon
and i do think it's a really important
tool but basically we need to learn to
keep fish healthy
use clean water there are basically
hygiene solutions
that uh need to be used and also
management decisions when we have an
epidemic
do you call the fish or do you let the
epidemic run
those are very important management
questions uh the vaccine is useful
in some cases we have one already uh we
need
the barriers delivery delivery to small
fish but i do think that we have to be
careful how we use it
dr kirat this has been a great workshop
do you have any closing remarks
for our audience before we go today
oh that's very fun um i do think it's
kind of
important to keep in mind uh
how useful virology of all hosts is
uh we tend to focus on mammalian
virology and
um human virology because of course it's
important in human health
but we can't conduct the kinds of
studies that we can do in juvenile fish
in humans we can use 1500 fish in an
experiment you can't even do that in
mice
so we're trying to use the fact that
they're low sentient animals
to study basic virology and um
there's a lot of beautiful work in phage
uh in
in phage interactions uh and infections
in plants i think uh i just think we
need to be
more synthetic in taking all of our
algae into account and
using the strengths of each system to
inform the other that's my little
soapbox
thank you again dr kirath for your time
today
and for your important research and
before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today for their
interesting questions
and questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast
can be viewed for up to six months till
march 2021 labyrinths will alert you via
email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time stay safe
stay healthy take care bye
thank you